hello and welcome to another fascinating
episode of the into the impossible
podcast featuring yours julie brian
keating chancellors distinguished
professor of physics at the university
of california san diego and i bring to
you interviews with luminaries brilliant
brains magnificent minds from a
constellation
of creative curious geniuses and i'm so
blessed today to have on the podcast
none other than dame jocelyn bell
burnell
who is a hero to millions around the
world she's one of the few people living
today that's discovered a new class of
astronomical objects
in this case she discovered pulsars but
these pulsars weren't initially
recognized for what they are they were
thought to be little green men
signatures of an alien extraterrestrial
intelligent species perhaps
in fact she gave them the initials lgm
to
denote the fact that these could be
possible signatures because they are so
periodic so regular so repetitive
repetitive
that they seem to be the byproduct of
technology after all the best time
keeping devices that we have on earth
are made by human beings with
intelligence so
in this case
she was maybe a little bit dismayed to
not find discovery or evidence for an
extraterrestrial civilization
but instead the magnetized dead core of
a of a neutron star magnetized very
highly magnetic star that puts out a
pulse of light that we can see
throughout the cosmos using telescopes
and like the kind that she built so
she's an experimental astronomer she
actually built the telescope the radio
telescope that was used to detect these
objects for the first time
and unlike yours truly she truly did uh
perhaps lose a nobel prize that she
deserved in fact the nobel prize for the
discovery of these objects went to her
ph.d advisor you'll find out about that
and the story behind that as we go on in
this interview but she has no remorse no
regrets she has said in the past she's
glad she didn't win it
the nobel prize that is because now
people ask her about it all the time and
they probably wouldn't if she had won it
now i think that's maybe just
tongue-in-cheek
but she is a delightful uh human being
and i couldn't be more pleased to
present this interview with a really
truly titanic observational astronomer
experimental astronomer and someone
after my own heart who just has such a
cheerful wonderful disposition we got
into many things including the uh
aspects of philosophy and even
metaphysical existential questions
you'll hear at the very end the
so-called final three thrilling three
questions that i ask all my guests to
honor me by coming on the podcast so sit
back enjoy this ride into the impossible
with dame jocelyn bell burnell
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
open the pod bay doors now
[Music]
welcome everybody to a very very special
edition of into the impossible featuring
a guest um who is so renowned and so
fascinating that i was dying to wait
even six months in the making to have a
bit of her precious time to spend with
us on this day and actually we're
supposed to record this last week which
would have been december 10th which is a
day that lives in infamy for many
scientists as alfred nobel's death day
we'll get into that but it's uh it's
dame jocelyn bell bernal um i i hope i
can call you dame or but i've never i've
never addressed somebody
don't call me dame joslin will do
okay
well it's great to uh great to be with
you thank you so much for coming on the
show
thank you
and i want to open with by addressing
the elephant in the room which has to do
with a very simple acronym
lgm
is it really true that you thought for a
moment that the pulsars the very first
astronomical objects discovered via your
brain not just looking at them in the
sky uh that you thought they were
originally little green men men perhaps
alien civilization was that ever a
serious serious uh contemplation
no it was a tongue-in-cheek nickname
that i gave these things we needed some
sort of short name you can't or talk
about you know that funny source we keep
seeing at 1919 plus 23.
[Laughter]
yeah indeed so um i i was you know
ruminating you know last night as i was
looking over your books and your work
and there's a wonderful uh short
documentary about you uh in the new york
times from earlier this year i will link
to that in the video and text
description but i was thinking you
really did do something quite remarkable
perhaps for the first time in human
history which is that you use your brain
to discover something not just your eyes
through a telescope because you made
these first discovery uh of these
objects which we call pulsars to this
very day
and i was thinking about all the
serendipitous things that had to come
about for that to happen the right
wavelength the right time the right
instrument
and i wonder if you can tell me are you
as fascinated by pulsars now as you were
when you discovered them you know 54
years ago
uh just to backtrack slightly i think we
don't want to imply that nobody else has
a brain
that's true although some of my faculty
colleagues no i'm just kidding no no no
no don't go there
um i haven't worked on pulsars um since
about 1968
but of course i have followed the field
and a fascinating field it has turned
out to be with a lot of very interesting
stuff
and a lot of quite tough problems as
well understanding how these things
radiate
and
what do you think is the most
fascinating thing would you say about
these objects are they is it that they
you know kind of have this regularity
associated with them is it that they are
the heart of these you know corpse-like
explosions massive explosions is it
their cycle or is it their very
precision which which fascinates people
most what do you think is the most
valuable aspect of these strange and
wonderful new objects that you discover
they're certainly stretching our physics
understanding in many ways
first of all they are very dense objects
there's a solar mass of material in a
ball that's 10 kilometers radius so the
density is phenomenal and the physics is
staggering
um
how they radiate has proved to be a
pretty tough problem
that's really because we're at the
extremes in in every dimension you can
think of relativistic high electric high
magnetic and so on so it that's
interesting but a tough problem that's
i think close to being cracked um
and we're beginning to
link the pulsars with neutron stars in
other environments as well
and
you know looking back i i guess i failed
to realize and it's probably you know
just my
incompetence but i didn't realize you
built the the telescope that you were
part of the team that built it as well
as observe with it as well as analyze
the theory of it is that error of kind
of you know science from beginning to
end from
conception
obviously um you know you and your
advisor will get into tony in just a bit
but but you know his kind of coming up
with some idea some funding you building
it instantiating these ideas then you
discovering this then you convincing him
that they're real when he thought they
were perhaps a spurious systematic
signal is that eric gone i i had a taste
of it as a grad student 25 years ago but
i don't see it so much anymore is that
is that should that worry us as a
community
i suspect the era of home built
equipment is passing
we're certainly in in astrophysics we're
more and more using
big facilities
huge telescopes you know getting an
allocation of time on them with luck
um so it is a different way of doing
things
but all instrumentation starts with
something fairly simple and
built in in your home university
laboratories so
that's the way many things start and
when you um had to take this strip of
chart paper to your advisor to tony
hewish um he was skeptical at first and
as i recall a recounting that i heard
somewhere on the internet archives um
you know you almost missed it if you had
been looking in the wrong place perhaps
20 minutes or come 20 minutes later 20
minutes earlier perhaps you wouldn't
have
found it again but what was that like i
mean how did you have the intellectual
fortitude to convince a much more senior
scientist he was world renowned at that
time even
how did you do that what gave you that
confidence is that something that you
were born with or is that something by
virtue of the fact you had to work so
hard to overcome so many barriers you
had built up by that time
when did the re what did the full
jocelyn bell burn out when did that
fully come out
i think it took a bit of persistence to
um first of all find the things
you know i i had miles of paper chart
literally i can't remember whether it
was three miles or five miles but you
know something like that
and this first signal was occupying
about a quarter inch
so it's a very tiny part of the full
thing so i think persistence was
actually
uh the main quality persistence
persistent careful work
and
looking at the kind of breakdown between
theory experiment observation
analysis what appealed to you the most i
remember you said once you got you know
a set of kid of tools you know uh
spanners and and wire cutters and stuff
and and it was very obvious to you that
that this type of astronomy is very
different than other forms of astronomy
what appealed to you the most was it
being in the field taking the data
working on the instrument trying to
figure out its peccadillos or is there
something else the observation the data
the writing up of publication what
aspect sub aspect of all the things that
you do and did is most appealing to you
well the data analysis is always
exciting particularly if it's a piece of
kit that you yourself have built
you're actually seeing it working
and half of you is sort of checking that
it is working okay
and the other half is looking at what
it's delivering in terms of science
so that's always a very satisfying and
exciting part of any project it works
and here's some data folks
and as we uh go back in your world line
your history you um you were
came from northern ireland and and uh
and then eventually made your way to
cambridge and i recall you saying you've
really battled uh this notion of the
imposter syndrome
and um and i found it uh interesting i
wrote recently wrote a book with a
forward written by barry barish who won
the 2017 nobel prize with ray weiss and
kipp thorne and he wrote the forward
he's very gracious but he told me he
felt the imposter syndrome after winning
the nobel prize in other words when you
win a nobel prize i mean i i wrote a
book called losing the nobel prize but
you know i didn't come as close to
losing it as you did uh and and i want
to get into that and my audience has
questions to talk about that as well but
um but barry said when you win a nobel
prize you have to sign this little
ledger and the ledger says you know yes
i you know insert your name i won the
nobel prize got my medal um got my share
of the prize money
and then barry is very curious so he
looked back who won this before and he
looked back and he saw feynman and fermi
and then he saw einstein and he said i'm
not worthy
i'm just not worthy of being in the same
group as einstein he felt like a fraud
and i told him on the interview when
when he did my show i said barry guess
what einstein had the imposter syndrome
he thought isaac newton was a far
superior intellect and changed the
course of human history more than any
person before or since
and i said furthermore uh isaac newton
lived in awe of jesus christ and felt
like no he could never approach him and
so do you think this is endemic um you
know to all scientists or is it more
prominent in female scientists
or underrepresented minorities
is the imposter syndrome a generic
feature of being a scientist that we
just have to learn to cope with or is it
something you can truly overcome
impostor syndrome can happen to people
in any field of work
i was interviewed by a journalist who
said you know all journalists suffer
impostor syndrome you're only as good as
your last piece can you do it again
so i think it's probably quite
widespread it's just not talked about
very very much
yes
and i think tools to overcome it is is
probably to recognize that right that it
is so widespread and that you're not the
first um yes and i think you know
especially with with i have daughters
and
and i have sons and um you know i do i i
think that there's a tendency for us to
look at someone like einstein as barry
barish himself did and say i'm not
worthy but at the same time you know
einstein wasn't always einstein you know
he had he had grew up like anybody else
he didn't come out knowing uh you know
the uh the theory of relativity he had
to work on it um
that's right and i also point out that
einstein was right at least at least
seven times he had amazing insights into
the nature of reality but he also has
about seven or eight huge blunders not
the least of which was about uh the
cosmological constant um which he later
to his credit you know recanted his
disavow
but he also didn't believe things like
gravitational waves would exist and in
fact you know barry discovered these
along with his colleagues and the whole
team
um and and so but we never focus on
these kind of foibles of of great
scientists we just kind of teach it to
our students they came out with the
right answer here's how it is let's
rewrite the history books um how would
you change the way that we teach people
as young people is there something we
can do to minimize not just the imposter
syndrome but to maximize
the the product of their of their
quality and their quantity you know how
many of them there are and how how
powerful they can contribute to our
knowledge of science
being a woman of course you often get
put to teach the first years the
incoming class
partly because the department is keen to
show the young women that there are some
women in the department
even if there aren't very
so you're you're not just there as a
teacher you're there as a role model and
to some extent an advisor as well um
which is okay you know once you
recognize that
um
not sure it's recognized by the rest of
the department but
they'll get there one day
i very much enjoy explaining things uh
to students
i've done a lot of teaching for a very
interesting university in britain called
the open university
which teaches students at home they're
in jobs and they study at home in the
evenings
and uh
these days a lot of it's done over
internet um there used to be um the
lectures quote lectures used to be
broadcast on television
and there were radio broadcasts and
things like that so that was a very
inspiring place to teach because the
students were mature adults who somehow
had missed out on undergraduate
education at the normal time
were more than capable of doing it
although they needed some convincing um
it was quite scary you know for a 40 or
50 year old to decide right i'm going to
do a degree alongside my job
but a number of them do it they were
superb people to teach when think about
teaching also as teaching graduate
students i think a lot of the importance
that i see is um is with you know regard
to being a good role model
and
i was
talking earlier this this year with
brian schmidt who won the 2011 nobel
prize and he was recounting basically
an embarrassing set of events where in
the collaboration that he was involved
with and their competition
had a what he called toxic competition
and that he demonstrated really poor
form
you know amongst uh you know scientists
for these young people even though each
collaboration
made sure to emphasize the work of you
know he was a postdoc when the work was
done and here he wins the nobel prize
his his fellow mentee um adam reese wins
a nobel prize he was a grad student and
their advisor robert kirsch bob kearse
didn't
and uh in contrast to saul perlmutter
and so he was saying that they could
have done better they could have really
shown this this uh behavior that would
be more befitting to model for young
people and they failed to do that and he
was embarrassed of that now he's a vice
chancellor basically a president of um
of the australian national university
i wonder you know is there because i
just i always find that there's a um
there's a fine line like you don't want
to be too close to your students i think
that can be dangerous um you know
there's all sorts of of stories
especially nowadays you have to keep a
professional balance but sometimes they
come to you with personal issues and so
forth how do you strike that balance
they're looking for wisdom they're
looking for a role model how do you
recommend you know people like me
balance the kind of authority that we
have and the responsibility that we have
but also the need that sometimes the
student wants to feel you know um dennis
shiyama said the most important thing a
student needs is love
now obviously it could be very you know
should be platonic but but how do you
balance that kind of you know almost
familial relationship but you're also
their boss
for advice for faculty now
interestingly my first grad student is
now my boss
and a very good one he is too it's great
it's brilliant to have him in the place
that's wonderful yeah so in academia a
lot of relationships can be quite
complicated
uh and i think it's important to behave
ethically whoever you're dealing with
whether you think it's a
fairly dumb student or whether it's
a much respected professor um
i think too much of
science in the western world has
involved rubbishing somebody else
rubbishing their work
sorry you'd probably say trashing yeah
that's right
uh and i i wouldn't do that to be honest
i'm not competitive enough to survive so
um speaking of competitors that were
really kind of like enemies
uh you grew up of course uh working with
um learning from uh sir fred hoyle you
credited his book frontiers of astronomy
if i'm not uh mistaken with in inciting
this love of astronomy and this
curiosity
that's when i was a schoolgirl yes
and he was a wonderful writer he was a
wonderful uh scientist
and he was a mentor actually had on
um you know one of his one of his uh
former students giant narlikar um who
probably left before you were there uh
but giant is still working hard uh and
and puna india and uh he recounted you
know just
a real love affair that he had with with
uh sir fred hoyle talk about fred um and
the combative bombastic nature that he
had but also this brilliant gentle side
that he had that he would come to your
defense i've always wanted to ask you um
do you think that the support that he
showed was purely driven by scientific
integrity in other words he was one of
the most foremost supporters that you
should have won the nobel and it wasn't
fair
you know at that time um was that only
driven by you know support and
scientific integrity or was that
partially because of the desire to trash
rile and and maybe hewish i don't know
um can you i think you're right
i'm guessing but i think you're right
there yeah
what was hoyle like was he was he at any
time kind of a you know surrogate
advisor or confidant or was it you you
would um right cause you i remember yeah
go ahead
i i think i only really saw him
twice in my three years um
he lectured to us grad students gave us
two three lectures
um
i remember he forgot to convert parsecs
cubed to centimeters cubed
in one of these calculations on the
blackboard
which we grad students noticed but
didn't tell him
let him go through and he says oh
i think i've made a mistake somewhere
and we said yeah two lines up sir
he was in a different institute so i
didn't have very little to do with him
but he also mentioned in an interview i
saw with you you know when um when tony
gave a lecture to cambridge about your
discovery um he was in the audience and
immediately grasped the significance of
it what was that like was he was he
really this other world i mean we we
know him as sort of an iconoclastic
bombastic figure as i say but um what
was that like to win did you appreciate
that at the time or was that appreciated
widely at the time because it seems to
be quite
significant yeah i was really impressed
because
tony's
introduction of the account of the
discovery and what we'd find took about
40 minutes
tony ended up by saying he thought these
things were white dwarfs because he
fancied a model where this white dwarfs
oscillating
and launching shocks
and fred hoyle was the first to speak at
the end of tony's talk and he said in
his best yorkshire accent i don't think
it's white dwarfs i think it's supernova
remnants
and fred has hit the right explanation
within 40 minutes from cold
wow the impressive
so i never met him um uh sir fred hoyle
but i did know giant i do know giant
arlakar and of course i work at the
institution where jeff and margaret
burbidge were and frequently uh fred
would come here and uh giant would still
come here even after i arrived in the
early 2000s
and i wonder you know uh still
to this day giant believes that the
universe didn't have a big bang and and
i wonder you know as a student i feel
like he's so overwhelmed by the
brilliance of fred that he really won't
consider any other alternative that fred
could be wrong even though fred himself
admitted he was wrong on occasion not
not very often um but uh but but you
know taking aside these things like the
archaeopteryx and all the kind of maybe
silly stuff that that he indulged in um
do you think that he ultimately hurt his
case and his you know position for the
record book so to speak not not so much
the nobel prize but just the record
books and and being rightfully
considered one of the you know titans of
astronomy
of the of the previous you know century
at least what did he heard it because of
his lack of you know perceived lack of
collegiality per se and and that have a
negative impact on his students i guess
the thing i'm getting at is what
responsibilities do we have as mentors
to our students like
if we're taking a flight of fancy is it
fair to them that they have to go on
this flight of fancy with us
right there's about three questions in
that brian
i'm sorry
talking about the grad students and our
responsibility towards them
um i think some flights of fancy are
perfectly in order as long as you make
absolutely clear to the student
that this is a what-if situation
it's good to explore what ifs and i
think it helps
stretch the grad student education
but that's only a minor excursion away
from whatever the main theme of the grad
student project should be would be my
token but absolutely no harm stretching
everybody's thinking by occasionally
saying what if
i'm going on some wonderful ramble
yeah
i like to point out you know nowadays
you're not active on social media look
good for you but um but i like to do a
thought experiment you know if you were
to take a young scotsman in the 1860s by
the name of james clerk maxwell he had
come up with these laws that would later
be validated not really much in his
lifetime but he came up with these laws
and they're actually correct you know
these four uh fundamental equations of
of electromagnetism but his view of what
was
you know causing light to propagate was
that there was an ether and that
embedded in ether with these gears and
vortices and world and so um imagine if
if karl popper had existed back
this is crazy uh you know this is
falsified we don't see whirls and
gears and so your theory is wrong and i
wonder you know if the flights of fancy
can be
um stymied stifled suppressed too soon
and that yeah maybe you do need a little
bit of that but but with the caveats
that you just mentioned so uh speaking
again about um
about the actual detection the fact that
you built this instrument uh with with
collaborators and then saw it um i
remember
brian it was to tony's design it was it
was sure sure enough um and he got the
money
and that the original intention was to
look for
uh quasars right if i'm not mistaken and
that was uh around the time this catalog
came about and of course uh
ryle had had assumed that they were you
know he could use those to provide some
evidence for the expanding universe and
source counts etc etc um and uh and
nowadays we don't we use very different
types of radio telescopes to look for
these signatures um but at that time you
know it's often said um johnson that you
know the discovery by pensias and wilson
killed the steady state but i think
you're actually a counterproof to that
in other words in 1965 the big bang had
been you know uh you know bolstered by
the cmb discovery in 1965 you were
operating in 1967 so two years later so
what was the prevailing attitude were
you looking for these quasars to give ev
or to study them in their own right or
to maybe provide evidence for the
expanding universe what was your
intention or you and tony what were your
intentions in that conducting the survey
my intention was to find more quasars
because at that stage we only had about
20
and
we knew they were distant we knew they
must be very extreme exotic objects but
20 is not a good sample
that was the main project and in fact by
the time i'd finished we had about 200
so that was successful
and
and then they would uh and to get
detoured from that was it instantaneous
uh i remember you saying once that the
most important you know piece of
evidence was finding the second pulsar
not the first one no because that really
convinced you that they were real and i
think that's true i mean if you look at
ligo they really didn't go public until
they had two events um you know black
hole mergers
how hard or easy was it to tear yourself
away from the intended research goal you
know did you worry it would delay your
thesis your graduation how did it affect
you to switch completely serendipitously
to a completely different literally
alien field
well it involved the same data
so the data i was collecting served both
which was handy
and then um by the time the
significance really sunk in and was
accepted around the world um of course
there was a lot of you know publicity
you know and a lot of in fact it was was
sexist and and kind of focusing on your
measurements and and your appearance and
so forth and so on and and yet
my late great colleague here at uc san
diego margaret burbridge she rejected
famously prizes that were only allowed
to go to women um
what would you say to margaret like she
when when she rejected the annie jump
cannon award or because she she didn't
believe awards should go specifically
based on one's gender um
did you i mean obviously she's entitled
to her opinion or she was uh when she
was alive but but what do you what do
you make of that sentiment that there
are people that say we shouldn't
prioritize you know gender and even as
as you're doing now which i i commend uh
with your breakthrough prize um um you
know our winnings to a woman
scientifically proven to be the real
deal jocelyn bell burnell
that you've turned that towards the iop
and dedicated towards
underrepresented minorities as we call
them
do you feel there's an argument against
such things or do you feel like no it's
necessary to do
even even at this at this time
i
think one of the
significant factors in the discovery of
pulsars
was that i was an outsider
i was a young male i was not from the
affluent south east of britain i had not
been to an expensive school i had not
done my first bachelor's degree at
oxford or cambridge
and so i think that
diversity is important
and that's what i would focus on
try and get a much more diverse
scientific workforce
and to incentivize that
uh i wonder you know nowadays of course
you can't get a job in america at least
without um you know almost an equal
amount in the university of california
has put on contributions to equity
diversity inclusivity that's part of
your your package and it's held up
alongside with your teaching and your
contributions to research
and you know my concern sometimes is i
don't know anybody who says that they're
a sexist like
they just don't say it and we have all
this training and and maybe they are
maybe they're not but i often feel to be
honest with you that that you know
things are getting better i mean we went
from
margaret being the only female professor
here and now we've got you know four or
five in astronomy alone and it's out of
a group of 12 you know or 13. so it's
quite almost exactly equitable and it's
it needs to get better but it will um
but i feel like we're kind of paying the
price for the bad behavior of the
generation that you're describing that
you had to contend with how how should
we balance that those of us who are
raised you know not to be sexist and and
it's sort of in our we we can't conceive
of it in the same way that it was
commonplace they used to hoot and holler
at you you know when you came into class
you've spoken about that we that's
that's completely anathema to everything
we we do nowadays so
we're we're kind of riding this
exponential tale of maybe past behavior
that was that was really quite sexist
um
how should we approach that now um is it
is it is it necessary to over correct in
a sense or will it naturally take care
of itself as more and more women get
into the workforce and get into the
educational force so to speak
i think the question you have to ask
yourself is
um if you didn't have that arrangement
at what rate would women be getting into
the workforce
adequate
my hunch is it needs a bit of a push
it's not a permanent push it's a
temporary push
interesting
um and
i think you know nowadays of course
you're you're um you know in in your
retirement i said i should say uh you've
turned you know a long time ago away
from from pulsars can you say like what
things just as um just as a scientist
are you most interested in it doesn't
have to be in astronomy but what kinds
of things fascinate you intrigue you and
and what advice would you give to a new
up-and-coming uh you know phd student
who's just eager and she she just wants
to you know learn as much as pos what's
the most fascinating thing if you were
to start your graduate school career
right now what would you advise such a
person
when i was an undergraduate my final
year advisor was ron drever
and he was a very very stimulating
tutor advisor to have
and i made a mental note to watch any
field that ron worked in because it
would probably go places
after that he got into gravitational
radiation
so i've been watching the development of
gravitational radiation um with with
interest
indeed i used to lecture on it to our
grad students when i first went to
oxford about 10 or 15 years ago
it treated it as a bit of a joke
as the years went by it got more and
more serious
and then when gravitational radiation
was actually detected the theoreticians
decided they had to teach the course
resting developments there yes um i i
would say the opening up of a new
spectrum is extremely important
and that'll be a good area to watch
whether you want to work in it or just
watch it is a is another question
that's right the thing that's happening
in general in astrophysics is the time
domain is opening up
so not only do we have gravitational
wave events we have events in all sorts
of other objects flares and things like
that bursts and so on so there is a huge
amount happening within time domain
and i find that very very exciting
[Music]
so now i want to turn to your uh
wonderful
monograph
your
your book which is called a quaker
astronomer reflects colin can a
scientist be religious well i think both
of you
and myself are scientists so and we're
both religious um so i want to talk
about this because i found your
your
your book quite unique because most
scientists will say well i'm basically
an agnostic and i don't really you know
believe that there is no god maybe there
is no gutter um and i always say to such
people well and actually i had freeman
dyson was the first guest i ever had on
this podcast
and he said i'm an agnostic but it's a
great mystery i love and i said well
freeman how do you differentiate
yourself from an atheist because you're
saying you don't practice so if an alien
intelligent little green man
were watching you freeman
it would say
you don't go to the same church that
richard dawkins doesn't go to so how
exactly are you different from an
atheist in practice
and i find that almost none of my
colleagues many of whom are you know uh
uh you know professed to be agnostic
very few will profess to be believed you
know theists and even i myself don't
claim i'm a strict theist in the in the
classical sense of you know biblical um
you know realism but you have a unique
perspective and that you believe as i
understand please correct me if i'm
wrong
but you don't believe in you know kind
of the god of creation of the universe
and instilling and instantiating all the
laws of nature but you do believe in a
personal god
it's almost the exact opposite of many
people um that that i've encountered and
i wonder if you could elaborate on that
is that common in quaker um in the in
the quaker practice is there is there
something unique about you so first of
all maybe we'll start i'm sorry for the
long-winded question i do that on time
to time can you explain quaker isn't
we've all i've had on at least one
quaker i believe matt stanley and we
talked about eddington um but but can
you say a little bit about quaker for
those that aren't um familiar is it just
like ordinary doctrinated catholic
christianity etc
uh there's a huge spectrum of quakerism
in the united states so
um there isn't a simple answer to this
um the kind of quakerism i'm involved
with does not have priests or bishops or
archbishops
um reckons that anyone everyone can from
time to time be called to do that kind
of
uh ministry
but in the united states um as
uh european people migrated
westward
um
the quakers gradually evolved a bit and
you'll now find there are quaker
churches that have a service on a sunday
that is led by somebody
that wouldn't be the case in europe for
instance so there's now a huge spectrum
of quakerism in the world um
some with pastors and leaders and some
deliberately without
you talk in that book about your working
hypothesis of a living loving god who
works through people and calls us to
hope
and ethical action um so what is a
practice like in practice is it uh for
you is it is it a daily uh we'll get to
your studies of the mishnah
i'm fascinated by as a jew
but um what is it like on a daily basis
is uh for you personally is it is there
prayers or is there uh scripture is
there meditation how does it how do you
instantiate it
um
the
quaker worship is
sitting in
oh the quaker worship that i'm used to
is sitting in silence um
agitating
listening feeling
uh and and sometimes
you get useful thoughts which you share
with the other people sitting with you
um
[Music]
and i will do that two or three times a
week typically
a lot of it on zoom at the moment which
is is not so easy but
it's
sitting with people you
you pick up better what's going on the
non-zoom
you miss a lot of the signals when
you're on zoom
nothing
yeah and i wonder if that ties into you
know one of the biggest challenges to
a personal god for many people is this
issue of theodicy
you know of why do you know bad things
happen to good people why do good things
happen to bad people by the way which is
more annoying to you when something good
happens to an enemy or when something
bad happens to a friend
i don't
don't have an opinion on that okay fair
enough um so the problem of theodicy is
an old one uh you know how can a
personal just loving god as as you um
you know ascribe to
how can that be compatible
with the suffering the natural disasters
the viruses the the earthquakes and and
so forth um how do you reconcile that or
is that something you know that will
always be
an ongoing part of your working
hypothesis and in other words justin how
could you falsify your working
hypothesis in a sense no that's that's
about four questions in one sorry uh
stop i told you i i should have warned
you beforehand i am long-winded
sorry so theodicy first and then um and
then can you falsify your working
hypothesis let's do that
no i can't falsify the working
hypothesis and don't try to um quick
answer to that
um
no sorry i've lost the thread where you
started
well i guess yeah the notion of the the
personal god and incompatibility with
with that and happening to good people
etc is that is that something that could
be a permanent barrier uh that you
choose to overlook or is it something
that you know is an ongoing you know
struggle and that we just have to we
have to cut we have to cope with
you know you've made an assumption
god's there to smooth the path for you
and i don't think that assumptions right
so what does the personal god do i mean
he didn't create the universe and as i
understand it in your conception
um you know i should say in uh so so
what does he or it do
um
help you along the route by
um
[Music]
offering guidance is too tangible um
but
if you focus on god with luck your
decisions
will be
kind to other humans as well
so yes it's the process more than just
the
entity
in judaism as you know you know we
believe in the twofold manifestation of
god that god created the universe in
genesis 1 1
and then led us out of egypt um in in
exodus 1 1.
in other words that there's a personal
nature that god did intervene in the
events of human history and as a
scientist i you know i will often get
how can a serious scientist believe in
the bible so i'm going to ask you well
you're not as bible focused maybe as i
am but but maybe you are i don't know um
how do you reconcile that i have some
some
answers but my audience wants to hear
what you would say
uh i don't have an issue there you don't
have a problem
so
um
you mentioned in at the end of the book
that you enjoy uh leading and and
participating in bible study which is
loosely based on the jewish midrash i i
found that fascinating
how did an irish irish woman
uh who's a quaker how did she come to
even know what the midrash is so first
explain your understanding of the mishna
and then what does it do for you or what
do you do for it so to speak
um
this i was introduced to at a big quaker
meeting
in the u.s i can't remember now which
one it was um
where
in a study group it was suggested that
we read
together a passage of the bible
we each took the role of one of the
characters
and then
wrote up our diary or wrote to our
mother describing what had happened
in that story from the perspective of
the character we had assumed
and i found that extremely useful
because it
it rounded out a lot of the bible story
and so
something that
i find very very useful and
grateful to be introduced to it
yeah so yeah for those that may not be
so
aware
so ecumenical as jocelyn uh this is this
is a set of rabbinical collection of
stories that kind of fill in the gaps i
mean some of them are pretty famous
there's a there's a notion that even my
kids will learn about that you know
abraham
was put into a fiery furnace and that
was one of his tests um and and yet it's
never mentioned in the in the torah in
the old testament and that comes from
the midrash and it kind of explicates
these missing links so to speak between
in the story and then the talmud itself
is really a collection of case law and
interpretation of of these sentences
like you know thou shalt not murder like
what does that mean or an eye for an eye
that's the perfect one an eye for an eye
you know could kill somebody uh but it's
not what it means and so there has to be
some interpretation or kosher and stuff
like that so i found it very very
interesting and that you brought this to
um to a religious audience i mean this
is what it was for in the quakers and
and as i said earlier you know eddington
is perhaps one of the most famous
scientists who was quaker um and that
you know is believed to play some role
in his life as a scientist
so i love the fact that you you
basically say that you don't blame god
um you know for kind of the the uh the
workings orchestration of the universe
but you also don't give god credit
um and and oftentimes we'll hear that
from einstein like i believe in the
beauty of the of god as as evidenced by
the organization
but you
don't feel the same way as einstein
right
[Music]
so um
and the other parts of that book that
that are so delightful are really the
description of the modern
astronomers understanding
of the universe and how the universe is
is uh depicted not necessarily as an
organization did you find
people were receptive to it was it was
it um did it cause tension uh you know
when you when you i imagine there might
be people that don't believe as you do
even within the quaker
faith right um so how was the reaction
to this book
it was a it's the text of a lecture that
i gave um it wasn't originally a book
i gave it at a gathering in australia to
australian quakers
and it seemed to go down quite well
at a number of interesting conversations
following it
following the talk
um i do remember it being incredibly hot
we were in canberra
and i forget the temperature was but it
was very very hot and there were fires
further inland you know it was
australian summer it was
so
i think
people took took more than a polite
interest in it um but there were other
things going on at that conference
around that conference
interesting
okay so now we have questions from my
audience and uh apologies if uh and if
you don't want to answer any of them
please feel free uh but henry uh selden
says he's disgusted
after reading your history about you not
getting the proper credit for the work
you did
he wants this corrected and procedures
put in place to ensure this disgrace
never happens again his question has
what we've learned about radio pulsar
since you discovered them change your
perception of what they are do we know
for sure what they are and how they form
thank you for all that you've done to
promote our learning
i think we've got pretty good
understanding of what pulsars are
where we are still needing more work is
how they produce these beams of radio
waves that then swing around the sky so
we see a pulse each time the beam swings
past us
um
got this bit right but what the beam is
there's still work going on it's
incredibly extreme physics because
there's large magnetic fields large
electric fields rapid rates of rotation
and in the star itself extremely high
densities
it's hitting the extreme in every
dimension you can imagine
so it's tough physics
indeed it is
uh next uh
next audience member says his name is
timbo
do you mind if we call them belsars in
your honor
should we change their name from pulsar
to
uh far too late to do that
okay uh and then he says i've seen one
recent um
uh one recent
uh commentary from a documentary that he
saw your role shines brighter in the way
that she handled uh the snub by the
supervisor on the nobel committee where
respect for fred hoyle likewise
increased when i heard this objection um
okay so we basically covered those uh
already okay uh kenny wayne beak asks
you
i would like her to expand upon her
quote i believe it would demean nobel
prizes if they were awarded to research
students except in very exceptional
cases and i do not believe this is one
of them do you still stand by that
that's his question
largely yes but
um
i had to handle a lot of very tricky
politics around about the time of the
nobel prize
um
so yeah i think that's all i'd say
okay fair enough
um and then uh
so
he asks did you initially think the
radio signals were observed were
extraterrestrial civilization we talked
about that but let me ask you a
different question in the us at least
there's been a resurgence in interest in
what are called uaps ufos
first question do you believe that there
is um that there's any evidence for
extraterrestrial life of any kind um uh
technological or not in our universe or
let's just say in our galaxy
i don't think we've seen any sign of
life yet that would convince me no
would you say that it's therefore
not
terribly
uh wise to to make statements that there
has to be life out there because the
universe is so big in other words uh i
guess a version of the fermi paradox do
you believe there is life or do you
believe the question do you believe is
as is
insufficient or inaccurate
the universe is very very very large
i think it would be a bit stupid to say
there is no other life in the universe
there will be no other life there has
been no other life
it is so very very large um
i i think being that dogmatic is unwise
uh and uh
then the next question is what is uh one
cosmic mystery you'd like to see
demystified
uh dark energy dark matter inflation or
something else all of which you talk
about in a quaker scientist
i haven't got a particular favorite
i'm looking forward to the vera rubin
telescope coming online
because i think there's a lot more in
the time domain things that vary
um
that we have yet to find and i think
that's probably going to deliver it to
us in bucket fools
it's going to be a fantastic telescope
so
what i think will be the next
interesting area
a complication is that the analysis will
have to be done by computers
computers have to be programmed by
people who think they know what they're
looking for
so
you know if our computers had been
programmed if we had had computers to
program would pulsars have been
discovered
very good okay there are other questions
that have to do with uh the
folks that don't believe pulsars
really exist um and i guess that might
be a symptom of you know there are
people that believe that uh the earth is
flat
uh that birds aren't real and all sorts
of other how do you handle skeptics like
pure skeptics pulsars don't exist how do
you convince as hello rabbi hillel said
how do you convince someone while
standing on one foot
i'm not sure it's worth trying to be
honest okay
fair enough and i will not belabor at
the point
live and let live as they say
well we have now reached the point where
we'd like to discuss
the existential questions
of life including what i call my
thrilling three final questions that
have to do with telling your full story
in the context the challenges the action
and the epiphanies
that you've gone through in your
legendary career and you continue to do
and you continue to inspire
and i want to connect them uh to the
questions that i ask all of my guests if
you are willing to
dame jocelyn bell burneau would you be
willing to go into the impossible and
answer these final three questions
i don't know what they are brian so
let's see how we get on all right we'll
delete them if you don't like okay the
first one has to do with your ethical
will not your material will in judaism
we have a desire that people should live
to be the age that moses was when he
died 120 years old and like moses give
over a will of ethical content and
and this is sort of originally done by
the patriarchs in the bible but nowadays
they're for everybody uh including um
you know people of all different stripes
professions etc so i want to ask you
what what sort of wisdom
uh would you be tweet you've already
been so generous and gracious and and
bequeathing tons of literal
uh uh financial uh wealth to future
generations but what wisdom
or advice would you give to future
generations when you leave this mortal
coil as
shakespeare said at the age of 120
i hope i don't last that long
[Laughter]
well we hope you're right we hope you
will um
i i would say
try not to waste your life
make good use of the time given you
um be courageous you can be over
cautious
be generous be kind be thoughtful
very good
okay that wasn't so bad
um the next one has to do with uh sir
arthur c clarke's uh thrilling film 2001
a space odyssey i don't know if you've
seen it or not but the movie version of
it it depicts some
hominids in africa and they come upon
this monolith this huge structure and
they don't know what to do with it and
they hit it with a with a bone and
and then later it appears in space and
it's on the moon and it seems to be sort
of a time capsule or some sort of advice
or billboard placed by a civilization
millions or billions of years ago but
meant to be discovered when human beings
can appreciate it and unlock it and
maybe we haven't gotten to that point
yet i think is what the film depicts and
it reminds me of uh richard feynman who
said you know if you had to recreate
civilization after some cataclysm
what piece of knowledge or or would you
put on a time capsule that really be
speaks to what human beings have
accomplished and he of course talked
about the the atomic hypothesis what
would you put on a time capsule now not
a hundred years from now but a billion
years from now what what would you say
most signifies
the scientific heights that humanity as
a whole has achieved as of this day
gosh i've never thought about that one
um
i don't think i can answer that i need
you know to go away and
under it okay maybe uh in part two
someday if you'll grace me again um the
last question also has to do with sir
arthur c clarke and as you know he had
many laws one of which i open
every podcast with including this one
him saying in his own voice any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
he also said things like for every
expert there's an equal and opposite
expert and then the third thing he did
was give me the name of this podcast
because he said the only way of
discovering the limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible
and i like to ask that question of you
uh by saying what what kind of
mysterious thing perplexed you as a 20
year old or maybe a 30 year old as a
young person and what epiphany did you
have
that gave you the courage to go into the
impossible and push the boundaries and
the limits of what seemed to be
impossible at first basically advice to
your former self
i think i've been
pushing boundaries all my life
it's been hard being a female
who wants to have a career
of my a female of my age who wants to
have a career
um let alone a career in science let
alone a career in physics
so i actually think i've done a lot of
pushing of boundaries
um
the only thing i would want to add is
you need to be a bit subtle in how you
push the boundaries
go straight at them with a battering ram
i don't know if that answers your
question but no i think it does i think
it does and and the fact that you are um
so willing to be vulnerable and to talk
about your experiences with honesty and
courage uh it really has served as an
inspiration i i've you know i can't
believe i'm talking to you and it's been
it's been such a dream and such a
delight
to learn from you and to learn how to
teach from you in a certain sense the
graciousness that you have the
brilliance that you have and the dogged
determination of an experimentalist
who saw things through from the first
wire snips that she ever got um all the
way up through a discovery for all time
and i just want to thank you for
spending so much of your valuable time
with me and my audience and i i i can't
wait to see where you go next and and
hopefully we'll get to chat again in
person maybe someday
thank you very much brian thank you this
is a delight
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]